[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we
wanted
i feel like you haven't been on jk news
in like a year since before
quarantine dude was that right yeah yeah
what the hell happened to you
i barely even know you guys anymore your
hair is long as [ __ ]
my hair is not so long you got a haircut
yeah you got a haircut
wait you were able to violate covet
rules no no
i went way they opened it they opened
they reopened hair
hair places and my hair lady like full
on took my temperature and [ __ ]
how do they do that do they no they got
like a thing that they put up to your
forehead
it's like a laser or something they
don't even really do it right
because uh there's a gym next to my
house that does it and he doesn't even
look at it
so i go up to him and goes like this and
i just walk away
and then one time i saw 85 on there
which is like
super low yeah not even right yes not
even what that didn't even he didn't
raise any questions and i think it's
because i came in because it was raining
so my forehead was probably like wet
with
so he [ __ ] did the bead of water on
your fork yeah
and i just walked past him and i'm
looking at him like aren't you supposed
to check
the number but he you did it so i think
these people just do it just to be like
oh that's like i'm doing it right
yeah that sucks dude i had to do that to
get italian food
i actually sat down and ate at a
restaurant it was so nice yeah but they
came up and they're like beep
okay you're coming to a restaurant still
haven't eaten at a restaurant
what you should there's a lot of
restaurants open now i probably should
i did go to the orthodontist recently
and that was my first experience with
all this
like i had to sign a waiver for isaac
too and then we had to wait in the car
because we had our our appointments
separately i'm like this is
weird i prefer that to the waiting room
yeah we had to go to the vet a couple
months ago and they did like curbside
like pick up and just grab the cats from
the carrier which is pretty cool what
well what about the highlights magazine
though like i think the whole experience
oh my gosh
and that thing with the the yeah yeah
those big wire things
yeah the shitty wooden toys that nobody
wants to play
you just [ __ ] yeah even at a as a
child i thought that was the most
stupidest toy on earth oh i loved it
i don't think i was very smart though
never mind i take it back someone
doesn't want to play with it apparently
yeah yeah yeah yeah do you see the way
they test you with that swab um
they go through your nose and they swab
your testicles dude that shit's so deep
testicles i saw i saw a video of it that
[ __ ] goes deep dude oh [ __ ] it was so
scary okay the way you see it sounds
kind of hot
it goes in deep i'm kind of down no
because like the swab's like this long
yeah and i saw a video she goes in i'm
like oh and she goes
and i was oh my god it was so the guy's
like shaking in his chair just freaking
goosebumps i don't want to think about
that yeah i'm not doing it no have you
guys
seen i saw a um i saw a tick tock
where they show how they do pap smears
and the two
what jews dude they showed the vagina
they didn't show the vagina but there
was like a diagram and they showed the
tools that they use
i had no idea i thought it was the peppa
tippee so the pippa did the thing
right the peppa dipped it looks scary
yeah so that's the easy part regular
people it's like
okay metal part that goes in it goes
what the hell happened uh-huh
and i thought it was a swab and then
they go with your cheek like that
so they go all the way in where your
surface is to swab the outside
that's the first part the second part i
had no idea this was something that they
used
you know those [ __ ] um pipe cleaners
yeah to clean your straws
the brushy brush they go in there and
they brush these and the paper down and
the brush
brush bro like deep in there it feels i
feel it
why did you tell me this i don't i don't
have anything better to say
yeah i saw that and i crossed my legs it
was all oh it looks like it hurts
does your [ __ ] feel dry after or do
they moisturize
what no no wait what did that process
okay because if your mouth
because if your mouth is like this like
ah you're breathing in right your breath
so you think our vagina breathes
it can breathe in and out it could suck
air in
but we're not sucking i can hold my
breath like this and it'll still feel
dry
i feel yep i got i need to produce
saliva
yeah right it's a valid question does it
dry up
uh we do know what's going on i don't
think they
look at that they loop the tool oh yeah
it's like a cool man if they lube yours
good for you
yeah they do look mine and it's not
metal you've got a coaches
they just spit on it oh crawl yeah
well they lose they lose it right they
lose what they do they do right there's
a medical lube
yeah they put that same gel ky jelly
yeah
yeah it's actually okay is it ky it
really is k1
[ __ ] yeah like an industrial vat i never
used it
on yourself or on on in sex
on sex on sex
doing sex i know we used to do it on
doing the sex work sexing
yeah what did you use it for i never
used it
yeah you've never used ky jelly i had
strawberry lube it's a very lubricated
woman
oh so you've had lube before just not
specific ky
his name no i never i never bought it so
i can't be a good
um like reviewer he buys generics
oh okay there's only one time when i did
it
because i thought it would be a pleasant
surprise for someone to use strawberry
lube when they give me head
okay was it pleasant maybe for them
or were they surprised were they like oh
strawberry
can you imagine i got strawberry what is
that
it never actually tastes like strawberry
though no no it never does huh three
flavored things it doesn't
taste like strawberries don't taste good
period unless you're in japan oh my god
did you see that viral tick tock with
the with the strawberries
oh my god yeah worms what so you soak it
and then you put salt in it and then you
soak it for 30 minutes
and then you look at the strawberries
there's tiny little worms that come out
all the time all the time all
strawberries oh
no i did it i did it it didn't it didn't
do it oh
i did it because i'm i'm a follower okay
that's a relief and i saw
it and i'm like i gotta see so what's
wrong with those worms if it's been
there since the dawn of time yeah they
were like nothing's gonna happen
then let's just nothing you animal
there's nothing wrong with it
dude can you make all the [ __ ]
microbes in your eyebrows and [ __ ] just
eat it
like worms or eyebrows yeah there's
eyebrow i mean
life like slicing your eyelashes it's
been there it's just we know about it
now so it grosses the side everything's
disgusting
do you guys close the toilet like cover
the toilet before you flush
[ __ ] no i'm not savage girl you should
microbiology like the little microbes
like poopy particles and
particles they spray all over and onto
your toothbrush and stuff yep every
every person that's taken like a
microbiology class has always told me
this and i started except for this guy
what do you mean i don't think
microbiology he probably flushes huh you
did it
i didn't take michael he just took
regular biology not that much
told me though that ever since i said
that you've been closing yeah ever since
tiff told me i don't know when this was
maybe like
that he closes the lid when he flushes
and you believed him i did
what you see me do it you don't even put
the [ __ ] toilet seat down what are
you you don't even flush the toilet
if i'm duking if i'm duking oh
and i close it i flush it but in the
middle of the night if i go pee i don't
flush the toilet because i want to wake
you up oh that's
so that's why if you wake up it's a ton
of yellow you should be more
appreciative how could you
how could you slush does that mean it
doesn't
the pea crust doesn't go into the air it
does
so i would even do it with the pizza no
no no i'm saying if it doesn't flush
oh what do you mean so if bart leaves it
in the pool does it mean that it doesn't
have a pee pee fountain yeah probably so
public restrooms are [ __ ] yeah yes
they're disgusting every time i leave
now i like it when i leave a movie
theater i usually have like a drink
and a straw but then as soon as i walk
into that bathroom
i throw the straw away every time oh
smart
i never thought of that i actually don't
bring in things to the best me neither
but aren't we we're not smart but we
also don't do that
i like to drink on the john i bring it
sometimes because
there's a convenient place on the urinal
yup
who would steal your drinking if they
stole it it's okay they could seal it
outside that's why i don't leave it
outside
or what if someone's trying to spike
your drink you have no friends
no i have friends i don't want them to
hold my [ __ ] because i always get i
always get a cup that's bigger than both
of their hands
that's a regular size in america yeah
well what if you're just alone
and you're at burger king then you need
to reconsider your more things to worry
about that if you're eating inside at
burger king
i think what gio's just said applies
yeah what what's wrong with that
a lot of people do that though man it's
just sad how is that
sad it feels sad what do you remember
that mad tv show the
word expectations that's you
no you don't have to eat with someone
all the time all the time eating alone
is actually pretty nice no one talks to
you
it's sad that you you're so dependent
and you can't just be alone with
yourself
but not at burger king like a nice
restaurant all right
that was the point fine taco bell
excuse me miss fancy it's a little
better right it is better
belle god damn there you go taco bell
i got [ __ ] by taco bell over
quarantine it's become kind of a joke on
my stream because
i ordered it like three times and they
[ __ ] up i think like two out of three
times it got to the point where they
make fun of me now
i ordered tacos and a taco came with
just a shell and meat
what i sat there just staring at it like
this feels like a personal attack
somehow just the shell and meat
there's no what the lettuce tomato any
sour cream i think as i ordered five
tacos it was just that one taco i would
kind of get it it was all of them
yeah but there was just one we've had
crazy experiences like that i remember
getting a
chicken uh chicken nuggets right and i
get back to the office and i open it up
and it's a chicken breast what what
chicken breast
for my bottle instagram yeah wait i
think i remember this remember that yeah
from mcdonald's
yes the one down the street the hell
just the chicken breasts and i'm like
they don't even have real chicken for
the chicken sandwich
i love mcdonald's they don't get 100
real chicken [ __ ] that's what they
said
i love mcdonald's you know with the fake
grill marks yeah yeah yeah oh really
one it was the one with the i was like i
thought it was at least the bread and
chicken
it's it's the fake grill mark chicken
breast would you know
huh what'd you do it's [ __ ] cute i
don't even know if i went back
but then the next time i went back
i think that um i saw some guys that
were extremely high
and it answered see that's why you have
to
order your food from postmates
so recently i've been timing my meals i
don't know if you guys they won't mess
you over they won't do you guys time
your meals or no
yes so for me like let's say i know that
i'm gonna get hungry in 30 minutes
so i just post mates 30 minutes to 45
minutes ahead of time so it comes
exactly
like after a movie after a tv show after
work out whatever and efficient way to
use your time
smart yep and i've been doing or
sometimes even if i'm coming back home
from here
i'll post mates here so that when i go
home it comes
exactly at that time and i always get
wobble grill for my healthy foods
so if you're like bart you probably
start thinking about what to eat for
dinner
while you're eating lunch and we all
love food so that's why i love using
postmates they deliver food from every
restaurant i can think of
right to my door but postmates doesn't
just deliver burgers and sushi
they actually make life easier with
grocery delivery and whatever i can
think of delivery too
alcohol yes convenience stores
that's crazy i will have you now class
nice thank you i wish we could get
unlimited breadsticks from olive garden
i know that'd be a good hack so you
don't have to go
to no more trips to the store no more
late night fast food runs i don't even
have to worry about where to grab lunch
anymore
just download postmates on ios or if
you're one of the weird ones on android
find your favorites and get anything you
want delivered within the hour green
bubbles
for a limited time okay so postmates is
giving our listeners
100 free delivery credit for
your first seven days to start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
off the record that's the code off the
record for 100
of free delivery credit with no minimum
purchase
for your first seven days when you
download the post meets app anything you
need anytime you need it
post made it
i went to talk about a couple weeks ago
right and they do this thing now where
they
um they put um a sticker on the bag yeah
you'd be like yo it's
coven safe it's very secure bag you're
completely good
and then like you i had ordered tacos
and it and when i opened it it looked
like they stepped on
i was like why [ __ ] do all this like
hey your bag is safe don't
worry and then you put them back on the
ground just go
[ __ ] you guys man they have this thing
now which i call that the human
centipede chalupa
they have yeah i saw that yeah wait what
so imagine three chalupas but they're
attached so it's like a human centipede
oh i love that
does that count as one chalupa still uh
it would make me feel better if i would
licked your lips because i could
technically eat six of them but call it
two
dude do you think the taco bell product
people just get [ __ ]
stoned they get so high right like they
go have a creative meeting and that's
all they do is get [ __ ] high and like
what if we put all the chalupas together
just watch the human centipede he's like
guys listen oh [ __ ] i got something
he's like they won't notice so i ordered
that and i guess
the place didn't have it this is the
second time i got [ __ ] i guess the
place didn't have it so they gave me
three separate chalupas
all right cool the two of them were beef
and one was chicken
and i'm just like what is going on like
someone just got bored it's just [ __ ]
changing is this about the same taco
bell you need to stop
going there yeah these pools are hot as
[ __ ] it's become a joke i bet you
they're just really high
yeah do you guys like it when the person
that's delivering food drops it off
rings the doorbell runs away
yes or do you like when they stand there
no go away they wanna like make the
transaction leave me alone
i don't want that i'm not with you what
about you guys i like when they stand
there and they blink for a little while
before saying anything i like that
person too i look at them on our
doorbell and i'm just like
so you like opening the door and the
person's there no i don't i don't i wait
and then i just tell them thanks
dude i did the worst thing and i still
feel like [ __ ] for it like a month ago i
got postmates
and the oldest man in existence
delivered it to me
oh like this old chinese man he was a
thousand years old at least and he was
so cute that makes you feel bad
no no no so he had a mask and then he
delivered he had a little cute pink
basket that he would hand your food in i
was like this is the cutest [ __ ]
in the world
you're so lucky i'm not going to go up
your [ __ ] 70 flights of stairs
and i have stairs here's the [ __ ] up
part so the next day i decided to tip
him
and i was going to give him a 10 tip so
i typed in 1-0 and
send but it put in 10 cents oh oh
you can't fix them you could have
emailed
a [ __ ] sense he's probably old enough
to go
that's a lot of money oh no he's like i
remember when that was a [ __ ] ton of
money i know
wow like this [ __ ] [ __ ] i did
everything i could do
i know i did everything i could so
apparently after 11 hours you can't
change the tip that you give them i i
tweeted at post mates i messaged them i
emailed him like look i
don't want to feel like a piece of [ __ ]
this guy was so old
he probably died carrying that up my
steps
like three times and i probably died
from seeing the 10 cents i know that
gave him a little heart
[Laughter]
i thought you were going to say the next
day you're going down the stairs and the
old man's there like
like everest climber who got left on the
summit
he's there with his [ __ ] little boots
and he's like
with his frozen mustache
he did not make it from the summit oh
poor man you call him the ten cent man
oh
no that was the worst thing from eight
hours eight hours into his death
his phone lights up with your ten cent
tip
poor son of a [ __ ] you murdered a man
dude
i don't even remember 10 cents even
exists
like that's how insignificant that
amount is that's how rich he is i pay
for everything in 10 cents
it's a dime there's nothing so many
people out there right now are going
preach joe preach
[Laughter]
that's me me r and me rn
me r n that's what people that's what
they say the kids say that
that's what they said me af that's it it
is
a f yeah yeah see you got it wrong yeah
a-f-r-r-n
yeah okay yeah yeah i felt that yeah
yeah and then the rna
and the action special orange are like
well okay
me actually are in yeah actually yeah
damn now we gotta find the dude
i know all right what can we do to find
him dude i'm praying that he delivers to
my house again
he's probably like [ __ ] no not this is
the top of those stairs is 10 cents i
don't think so
i don't give old people a pass though oh
you're a horrible human
relatable man i don't get more people
duncan
just because he's old hey did he provide
good service
yeah he delivered but he was probably a
war criminal at one point so that's what
i'm saying he lived long enough to
probably committed more crimes than you
how has your quarantine been gina it's
been good it's
exactly what i've been waiting for my
whole entire life you guys all [ __ ]
suck going outside and [ __ ] i mean you
guys are dying
but me i didn't go outside no like we're
pretty introverted
liars no they like to go outside and
[ __ ] but it's been good for me
it's been good like we redecorated the
house you did
streaming a lot i got shelves what
that's nice
that's so boring i know it really is
what did you build it
absolutely not no my cat and i are
chilling out and he's oh my cat knows
how to sit now
oh my god oh cute you taught him uh so
no my friend taught him
so cool i don't do anything okay i can't
get it well she doesn't give him love
yeah that's all i do but other than that
it's just been normal for me
i still wake up at 1 p.m improvement you
need to flex on everyone in this room
right now oh
yeah that's right guess who was the very
first one here today
no i knocked on the door and nobody
opened up and i
freaked out i checked my text messages
from bart i
checked my emails from casey like am i
here the right day i was freaking out
and then i texted everyone where the
[ __ ] is everyone
and they go we're late and now i i just
want to say
that officially as of today i am better
than everyone in this room you are
i'm very proud of you i mean it's been a
few years but
i'm glad you recognize it thank you one
time only one time
everybody gets one that's it every
production gets one day of me being
early
that's why it's been so long because the
last time you were here pretty on time
mm-hmm
yeah see yeah everybody
[Music]
you